do you use index cards when you're
writing a screenplay
no i don't um i know a lot of people do
i've
tried working that way um and for me it
it's just not i don't know if it's a you
know
the way your left side brain or whatever
but i actually what i always use um
they're actually getting harder to find
those big legal yellow pads
and i just start i just start writing
and i start writing you know
sometimes um i'll get hit with a like
a little just a little snippet of
dialogue
that pops into my head and i'll write it
off to the side but i'll basically go
i'll keep working like this working my
way down
and as i
as i go through it and review it i might
see say oh well you know what
maybe i don't need that or maybe
maybe i should put this earlier and i'll
try to get as much of that as i can
again still leaving that that last
little bit
open-ended right um and
then i will sit down at a so i'll do
that with a pencil by the way
yeah right so then i'll sit down at the
computer
and i'll start writing an official
outline that will
that will actually go scene by scene
i'll always put in
little bits of dialogue that help that
just help with the tone
especially in a comedy um because i
mostly write comedies
i mostly should say i'm mostly hired to
write comedies
i like to i like to put in a little bit
of dialogue because sometimes that helps
just
establish for someone else who's going
to read it not for me
but for someone else is going to read
that outline um it
will help establish a character's tone
you know um and and also what the what
the
the overall tone of the comedy is is the
comedy
slap sticky like faulty towers or is it
more
you know more restrained um you know
some
you know more like um um oh i don't know
like election
a movie like election you know um
you can help you can help establish that
by having
some of the characters saved little
bits of lines or maybe a funny gag or
something like that or something that
just just
i i like the kind of uh dialogue that
you'd see
um in uh uh
like shows like the office and like park
parks and recreation
you know that that kind of banter i like
a lot
i try to you know try to not
not copy that but try to utilize that
same sort of
um that same sort of tone and that same
sort of uh snap sure yeah i was watching
master class and jody foster
gives a great master class and so she
was talking about little man tate
and how they they started you know
fleshing out these characters and
and it was just really fascinating to
hear about you know and you could
you could see if if you would if you
tried the test
of you know covering up the name of the
of the character and seeing you know
diane wiese's character i hope i'm
saying her name right and versus jody
foster and then a little what you could
tell
just kind of by the the way something
was said
you know jody foster was supposed to be
more working class diane was supposed to
be sort of this you know
a fluent snob that was you know so you
could just kind of see the difference
in who the characters were yeah do you
find that that that is a test for
you to kind of yeah you know what um
that's one thing that todd was
was always good at when we were when we
were writing together
was that i i mean i i would sh i would
give him
uh a pa show him the latest pass on it
and you know he would he would always
say like
does this line belong to this character
or
or is it someone else that has to say
that should say that line
um for this one of this one of the
couple of scripts that
i'm being um hired to write right now um
um which i should probably shouldn't
even say the name of it but
there are three lead women
characters and they're all um they're
two of them are elderly and one of them
is is much younger
and originally it was three elderly
women and on the third draft we decided
to make some changes and we made the
one of them much younger right just just
so they weren't all the same because
we were getting into a situation where
it was like who who who's saying that
line
right so that was one way that we solved
that
that issue by by having the one
character drop her down
you know from from being a 60 year old
woman to being
a a 30 year old woman well that
automatically just that change alone is
going to change the dialogue
her dialogue and it's also going to
change the way the other two characters
respond to her
right yeah and there is a generational
tone
to how something is said and i think
there's also an east coast west coast
midwest southwest north i think there's
different
like i noticed people from the east
coast say and so forth and so on
i don't hear that as much from
california natives
and they they might be like yeah and you
know so it just kind of continues or
whatever it's more it's looser
you know but there is you can there's
different uh
just like there's regional accents i
think there's regional
ways of saying something explaining
something yeah and that's that's
another thing too is um i i once um was
hired to write
um uh it was a it was a christmas
movie but it was set in um in new
orleans
and um so you know there's some
interesting accents yeah
right and the character characters
obviously they live there they're going
to have some of those
i'm going to have that accent and one of
the lead characters
was actually a cowboy from texas an
old an older gentleman so i was now
working with those voices in my head so
speaking we're working
with all these different kinds of uh of
accents now
and you know that so that that and that
way
believe me it was very easy to know
which character was saying what
but um but yeah i'm um
yeah you have to it's it's if the script
is going to work
for someone else not just yourself
for someone else to read it it has to be
very clear
what character is saying what
sure sure yeah and i feel like like
another term
a stone's throw away i don't know if
i've ever used that term
but i've known people that that they use
that in like every five minutes or
something you know so
it's just there's just certain like
catchphrases and different things sure
um idioms or whatever i don't know but
that people
yeah different areas right and you can
use though you can use those to assign
to a character
that will help establish who that
character is
um i mean certainly they they i mean you
see it in
in television series all the time
because they have to constantly do that
because it isn't just a two hour movie
you know you're talking about episodes
and episodes episodes and
so on and so on you know um my favorite
tv series of all time is faulty towers
the john cleese uh sitcom which only had
12 episodes
but it's to me it's the funniest show
that's ever been made and
if if you look at the scripts
um which they stuck to they'd like to
change a word of the scripts um
you can you can you can know who's
saying what line
very easily because those characters are
so well defined
and um that's part of what makes what
makes it so great
you